[Applause]
but first up he is the ultimate rock and
roll rebel also somehow found time to
become a really good actor his new book
is called unrequited infatuations a
memoir my good friend stevie vanzant is
over here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
okay hi crazy
finally i finally get you in my torture
chamber
only 30 years in the making i know i
know so i'm going to make the most of it
first of all i just got to tell you the
book i gobbled it up it's fantastic
i like the title first of all unrequited
infatuations awesome title i bet you
there are so many authors out there
saying i wish i thought of that for a
title
it says so many things the other title i
want to get to the rock and roll rebel i
said it there
you named your box set after that
it was years into making that title
right
and i feel like even among rockers who
are rebels
you're a rebel among rebels you think
that's true
well at the time
you know politics wasn't cool you know
you know in our business i mean
it's one of those show business things
right stay away from politics and
religion which you know you followed
it's been my mantra my whole career
stevie
so uh
i just kind of jumped in and made that
my identity you know i was looking for a
you know growing up in the 60s everybody
had a very very distinct identity
and when i left the e street band i was
like well how do i justify my existence
and uh i thought you know i'll be the
political guy you know talk about that
stuff and see i know you say you you
left because
uh you know you wanted more
in the decision-making process
but
actually you know when i look at what
you went from there i don't know how you
you could have coexisted because you
just wanted to be so much more political
and i mean a theme
throughout the book in your life is you
losing money
well it's not something
or foregoing money that could have been
money that was on the table that you did
not
[Laughter]
rake in because you chose this other
path because you are the rock and roll
rebel i mean i don't know how you you
could not have you could not have
can i just go through i mean the name of
your albums from the 80s they were all
so revolution
freedom no compromise right i mean voice
of america
um
do we have those pictures from those
albums because i just got to say
what
what was the look you're going for there
stevie
is it
i i i really think of it
whatever was in the closet a lot of
mascara okay um
it's a look but but the point is
you wanted to be this guy who did
something i've always said this about
music you know i think a lot of
musicians they big themselves up about
they can change the world but what you
did in south africa
really did kind of change
what was going on there
it was a lot of people a lot of people
involved you know the not just us the
four musketeers me danny schechter
arthur baker and hart perry but it was
really you know the united from the
united nations to all of the unions in
europe it was a big movement and we kind
of lit that with what we did like that
spark you know we didn't we didn't light
the fuse but wasn't it your idea to go
after sun city
yeah i mean if people don't remember i i
vaguely remember this that sun said it
was kind of like the las vegas of south
africa right it was this and i remember
everybody played it
frank sinatra opened it but lots of
people who are known as big liberals
in the music industry probably don't
want to be reminded because ever and
there was this pressure that you put on
it was like why are you going there to
south africa this is an apartheid regime
yeah and we made a decision you know
let's let's assume that they were
manipulated which they were you know
let's not let's not have an infighting
amongst the amongst the music people
let's keep our eye on the ball because
we had a bigger a bigger goal in mind
which was to raise enough consciousness
to get the sanctions bill passed which
we knew when it came up
ronald reagan was going to veto it
because he was part of that unholy
trinity supporting apartheid him
thatcher and coal you know uk and
germany you know
and um and reagan with god in those days
man he was this you know the
grandfatherly cowboy you know happy
cowboy
and all these crimes are going on you
know behind the scenes and um
we needed to raise that consciousness
enough
that when the sanctions bill came up
which was the really the home run you
know sports boycott first which was in
place cultural boycott was what we did
and then and then the economic sanctions
and uh once they came up he did veto it
and we and we overrode that veto because
we had raised the consciousness so much
you know and republicans
republicans voted for it okay richard
luger and republicans voted for the
sanctions bill can you imagine
republicans voting so black people could
vote different era
very different era yeah yeah but and you
did all that and yet you still didn't
starve
you still have some money
[Laughter]
the money thing it's not the money thing
so much it's well you know my i mean
i've had wonderful successes and i don't
want to ever sound ungrateful about
these street band and sopranos and lily
hammer and the sun city project you know
um
but but you know my own personal my my
most personal stuff you know my my
personal records that you just put the
screen up there uh have not found an
audience you know and and the point is
you know you're going to go through life
you're going to have some frustration
and you're going to have some
disappointment and everybody is and
that's where the universal themes start
to happen you know
um it's not it's not a matter of are you
going to be disappointed it's what do
you do with it what do you do after that
you know do you give up and throw in a
towel or do you kind of find a way to
move forward and i hope
i hope the book is useful that way you
know
you